stomach ache malaria sex problems I can
help you I'm the best doctor in town
traditional healer psychosis a project's
confidence he has his work cut out for
him in the small malian border village
of Korra Molly he tells the local
butcher this concoction can cure his
stomach ache in five hours he charges
the equivalent of two euros for his
cures a day's wages for many people here
we wanted to know if he had heard about
the Ebola epidemic in neighboring Guinea
Oh yep I Luca yes but I haven't met
anyone yet who has Ebola I believe in my
medicine and I'm convinced that good
health he's a new blossom but the
butcher with a stomachache says he'd
rather not depend on the traditional
healer if he had Ebola the state health
clinic is a short way down the road it's
director dr. drew sabelt a is very busy
this is one of his easier tasks
convincing a small boy to let him take
his temperature during peak malaria
season between july and november
children are examined once a month and
given free preventive medications the
doctors are able to deal with malaria
and it's not contagious
but there's no medication to prevent a
bola and dr. berty doesn't like to
imagine what would happen if Cora male
suddenly had to fight the epidemic we're
very frightened that Ebola will reach
here but what can we do today
fortunately I've only seen children from
Mali I haven't seen any mothers with
children from Guinea here that reassures
me a little I shatter coulibaly has
brought her two youngest children for
malaria prophylaxis four-year-old Fanta
bravely swallows the bitter syrup
everyone here has heard about Ebola and
i shotta knows thanks to dr. Betty how
to protect herself from the disease to
avoid Ebola we have to wash our hands
regularly not touch any dirty objects
avoid eating game and not go to burials
we'll keep to that i shotta and her
husband nidji earn a living from trade
with a neighboring country Guinea which
has been hard hit by Ebola they have a
prosperous village shop near the border
they sell peanuts and soap sugar rice
and gasoline nidji usually buys most of
his products cheaply in Guinea but since
a bola broke out there things have
changed Sonny this is almost ruined our
business I used to go to Guinea three
times a month but now I haven't been
there in two months we need help
countries like ours can't deal with a
crisis like this on our own I wheneva
tabu morning gallery had it for me
in the early afternoon it's time for dr.
Bell taze daily visit to the border post
unlike other West African countries
Molly hasn't yet closed its borders to
the affected region trade is still brisk
of course that constitutes a risk for
Molly since March all people entering
the country from Guinea are checked as
stringent lee as possible with an
infrared thermometer the doctor says
they had to force one woman to have her
temperature taken but everyone else has
been cooperative he says this woman's
temperature is about normal so there's
no problem in her case but what if
someone did have the typical symptoms
fever vomiting and diarrhea the doctor
takes us along with him not far from
Cora Molly the Health Ministry has
erected an isolation ward consisting of
a few temporary huts Nursery Rhyme a
light LED the antenna when dr. Betty
says they have room for four patients in
April they had three suspected cases but
fortunately they all tested negative
this is a waiting room in dr. lense any
doom bia's private clinic one of the
most modern health facilities in kaura
Molly his patient comes from Guinea
she's suffering from severe stomach
pains it's the only clinic in the entire
border region with an ultrasound device
well now my wife has suffered from these
pains for five years nobody back home
has been able to help her here for the
first time I have the feeling someone
can finally find out what's causing her
pain the lab workers are able to test
for typical diseases but they can't
diagnose Ebola here most patients in the
private clinic are suffering from
malaria people who go to dr doom bia
have to be able to afford it he charges
the equivalent of three euros for an
examination out
to that or the costs of medication lab
work and ultrasound scans it's too
expensive for many but his service is
the best in the area Phillies on Tommy
seduce you I opened this clinic here
because our state system doesn't have
enough doctors if patients in the
capital can't afford treatment they
might die that's why I've initiated this
project to help the people in the late
afternoon dr. Betty writes his daily
report to the health ministry in Bamako
the malaria campaign has been successful
and there's nothing unusual to report
from the Ebola checks he can only hope
that's not going to change anytime soon